hello freak [ __ ] what about the ideas
of the universe is in a constant state
of contraction no it isn't and man and
well I mean don't people think that know
something abandoned something cystal
argue that it's there's a cycle well it
looks nice and they are good I think
most of most people I mean there's some
people arguing for that you know I don't
find that something neat well I think
they're trying to type their ignorance
and something that isn't any more
plausible in the picture that it expands
forever and as far as we can tell the
most likely possibility is that our
universe will expand forever but to make
you a little bit happier it's quite
possible the best pictures that we have
of our of the early universe is that we
actually our universe isn't unique isn't
alone that there are many universes we
call it a multiverse and that at any
instant in time in kind of a cosmic
super time there's always universe being
born so that that multiverse might be
might be infinite and eternal where are
they outside of our universe how's that
impossible
of course it's possible I understand I'm
not questioning it okay no no here's one
line it well first of all the simplest
possibility is that they're outside the
region we can see right for for example
the edges of our visible universe space
is expanding faster away from us than
light because you know we taught you in
school nothing can travel faster than
light you may remember that from right
we lied okay well no you have to parse
it more carefully like a lawyer nothing
can travel through space faster than
light but space can do whatever the hell
it wants so locally as I told you that
radio host ism is at rest they're not
moving and the other end of the galaxy
the other in the visible universe and
we're rest but the space between us is
expanding so that galaxies like a surfer
is being carried away from us faster
than light relative to the water the
surfer isn't moving right but relative
the shore the surfer is right right okay
so this this galaxy is not moving
relative to its local surroundings but
its ruling away from us faster than
light and like a surfer and undertow
they can swim really fast in the water
but if the water is moving away from the
shore then let me get back to the shore
right and so that galaxy the light from
that galaxy is traveling through space
at the speed of light
but it's a space in between us and the
galaxies moving faster than light then
the poor light can never make it to us
we call that a horizon Wow
so the space is traveling too far for
the light to reach us
so our best the traffic base is too fast
so this light can't catch up with the
expansion of space and it never gets to
us and that that galaxy disappears from
our causal horizon we call it we'll
never be able to see it we'll never be
able to interact with it we'll never be
okay and it could be that that there are
different regions so far away from us
where space is expanding faster than
light which which have a very different
history than our own so there could be
space could be infinite just our simple
unity space that we know of and love
could be infinite in extent and
different regions of that space had
different histories in some of those
regions everything we can see we know
emerged from a single point okay we can
tell that we can tell that by measuring
the Big Bang expansion of everything we
see and working backwards in the
universe that our visible universe was
once smaller and smaller and smaller if
we go back in time we can actually
follow the laws of physics back to the
earliest moments of the Big Bang until
those laws break down and we can make
predictions about the universe should
look like all those predictions agree
exactly with the observations we make
which tell us that that picture works
but another region if you wish could
have come from a different Big Bang but
is that another universe or is it a part
of the universe now when you see here's
how we've changed and this is semantics
but
non-trivial semantics namely when I was
a kid universe meant every everything
right but we say that's a pretty stupid
definition a better definition is an
operational one universe means that
region of space with which at one time
we could have communicated or one time
in the future even if the futures
infinite we might communicate with
because that describes the region of
space where cause and effect works some
measurable distance yes and so that are
we think of a universe as that region
which could throughout which everything
could affect everything else ultimately
in an infinitely long time and in that
picture universes can be
restricted in size and then other
regions which could never have affected
us and which will never affect us in the
future we call other universes and when
and now there are many different
versions of a multiverse but that's a
simplest version and this picture we
call inflation which you know I talked
to I just did two little clips
associated with the new book of one
force for publisher and one was for big
thing one is a universe in under two
minutes so you can look up online look
for Lawrence Krauss explains the
universe in under two minutes where I
talk about this cosmic expansion and how
it might mean there's a multiverse but
the other is I explain the universe in
terms of this beer bottle that I talked
about to you earlier so you can that's a
video you can watch that but it this
theory of inflation which actually says
our universe could the quality qualities
that we see of our universe can best be
explained if some early time in the
history of the universe when it was a
billionth of a billionth of a billionth
of a billionth of a second old it had a
huge expansion suddenly and increased in
size by 30 orders of magnitude in size
in a billionth of a billionth of a
billionth of a billionth of a second
which is by the way particle physics
suggest is highly plausible even though
okay and then and then and then it would
produce the universe that looks more or
less like we looked like he looked like
and and and it's right now the only
explanation of how that would cause the
universe to look like what it looks like
but the neat thing about inflation is
it's eternal so inflation that puffing
up and it in our universe and then boom
a hot big bang followed it okay so the
region universe universe puffed up by
huge amount and all of that energy which
was stored in empty space got released
like the beer bottle and we got a hot
Big Bang and the rest is history
but that's locally but somewhere else
between us and air space is still
expanding exponentially and faster and
faster and faster and only maybe
somewhere else today boom like an ice
crystal forming boom that that region of
space is suddenly left inflation and
maybe a guilt the gazillion years in the
future to be another region of space
that's expanding away from it so much
faster than light so we'll never know
about it we're suddenly that region
leaves inflation and boom another hot
big
bang happens and it turns out in each of
those hot big bangs after the inflation
ends depending upon how it ends the laws
of physics could be different in that
universe and that's how we tend to think
it's quite likely that there are many
many separate regions of space and in
fact it's eternal
so such regions are forming eternally
for all time and and and there are hot
big bangs happening in many regions and
the properties of each of those regions
whether they're conducive to forming
galaxies and stars and planets and
people may be different so we could say
logically in that picture that the
reason the universe looks like the way
it does is because we're here to measure
it oh my god we should leave it at that
okay we should close with that that is
the mind blower grind blow it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]